Between stemming and the bag of words approach I think you're ready to do
a lot of really interesting things in text learning.
There's one more representation that I want to teach you before we quit
though because it's really, really cool.
It's called the Tf Idf representation.
Tf stands for term frequency.
Idf stands for inverse document frequency.
And the rough idea is this.
The term frequency part is very similar to the bag of words.
What this means is that each term, each word, is going to be up-weighted by
how often it occurs in a document, just like it is in bag of words.
If you have a word that occurs ten times,
it's going to have ten times as much weight as a word that occurs only once.
The inverse document frequency part is new though.
And the idea here is that the word also gets a weighting that's related to
how often it occurs in the corpus as a whole, in all the documents put together.
And here's a quiz to make you think about this weighting in a very careful way.
The question is this.
What do you thing makes more sense if you want to be extracting information from
these words?
Will you give a higher weight to the very common words that occur in many,
many documents, or would you give a higher weight to the rare words?
The words that might only occur in let's say 10% or
1% of the documents that are present in your corpus.